jeunesse est magnifique généreux d'un
courage extraordinaire
extérieur devant un public constitué de
militaires de journalistes de famille de
délégations du monde entier l'armée
terre a fait une démonstration de force
c'est une journée traditionnelle qui
permet de créer des liens avec ses
alliés alors aujourd'hui c'est une
journée traditionnelle de présentation
de l'armateur l'ihp dn voilà puis au fil
du temps on a élargi un petit peu la
présentation de manière en faire
profiter le maximum de gens dont
notamment les attachés de défense tous
les attachés de défense des pays avec
laquelle la france est amie
et parmi les délégations présentes il y
avait le japon une partie de l'afrique
de l'ouest comme la côte d'ivoire le
mali et le sénégal ou encore le brésil
et l'argentine ils ont pu voir durant la
démonstration l'équipement que les
militaires de l'armée de terre utilisent
au mali ou en irak par exemple donc
cette présentation et vocation à
rassembler un certain nombre de
composantes de matériel de l'aviation
légère de l'armée de terre on a pu voir
un certain nombre d'hélicoptères du nh90
caïman aux pumas en passant par le tir
mais aussi on a vu des groupes
tactique interarmes composé de diverses
matériel que sont le lot clair la mitis
p
vbc y
étaient joints aussi un certain nombre
de matériels
présenté sous la forme du convoi
logistique et puis sans oublier bien
entendu les artilleurs avec nos césars
le but de ce type de démonstration est
aussi de séduire le public l'armée de
terre souhaite recruter onze mille
personnes avant l'été 2010 est